and I want to say something to the
riders in the in LA and the studios and
all that work that [ __ ] out Oh is there
another strike strike looming work it
out please because let me tell you
something right now all right am i right
I did a pilot if the writers strike
could happen I'm gonna lose this [ __ ]
pilot okay and then I might indirectly
kill a writer or a producer allegedly
allegedly thoughtcrime I would never
kill anybody
I physically wouldn't be able to do it I
kept this is happening now so what's on
our agenda today well I will talk about
I'll tell you what my agenda is hmm
there's a couple of movies I saw as of
recently okay I'd like to talk about
okay the first one I saw is a movie
called split with you and McGregor
what's his name James McAvoy he's good
though he's getting are both that yeah
you wasn't it it was now you know so
here's my opinion about that movie okay
I'm watching it about an hour and I push
pause I look at kalila and I go yeah I'm
not into it
Oh spoiler alert a spoiler is coming
it's been you know why don't you undo
the spoiler oh okay I don't even do the
spoiler that's a chain okay and then
like 30 minutes in I was a gap for sure
this is not good mm-hm and then the end
happened a switch a surprise I've never
seen a movie where I went 180 like that
we're till the very end it was like I
was lukewarm about it like I don't you
know and then when I saw the ending I
look back at what I saw and I go that
could have been the best movie of the
year
Oscar I mean I literally when I saw the
ending of it I push pause I put my hands
over my face because I thought was gonna
weep and it crawled over to my side and
I went oh my god I can't believe it and
then I a couple days later I texted
Steve my brother because my brother had
seen it in the movie theater remember
that goes that was the hardest thing to
do what now tell you what the ending was
like he had to like you have to like
meditate
and pray about not telling me because I
remember him watching a movie that I go
that movies can't be good but Bob the
endings good he said I go no it can't be
there's no way but Bob and he was gonna
say say it to me then
but he's disciplined for the first time
in his life
Wow yeah so armed daya that movie was
the most surprising ending I've ever
seen and it was really good I liked it
[Music]